then we'll take a look at the txu pitch
arsenal for jordan lyles
a lot of red that's the fourth seam
fastball
slider and a curveball and an occasional
change on it so the astros get their
first two men
on here in the top of the first inning
with alex bregman coming up
there's a line drive to center field
that'll be down for a hit
altuve heading to third he held up a
little bit and will be
stopped at third base by omar lopez the
astros will have the bases loaded with
nobody out
still nobody out and jordan alvarez will
bat
ground ball right side gloved
by solac the throw to short safe at
first basis alvarez
that was a slow developing double play
the astros get a run out of it
and alvarez able to beat the return
throw here's the league guriel
and yuli sends one to left field deep
enough you would think to score the run
brantley will tag
he'll cross the plate astros lead two to
nothing
yielding ariel has done it again rbi
number 38 on the year
so far the bounces are going the astros
way
tucker hits this one in the air to left
field but playable
for willie calhoun and the inning is
done the astros will take two runs
in their half of the first now the
rangers ready to come to back lance
making his ninth start of the season
two or fewer runs in seven of his
previous eight including his last start
against texas he's the only guy in the
rotation who had an extra day of rest
on this road trip back to back walks now
face
nate lowe with two runners on called
third strike
locked him up on a fastball on the
inside corner lance mccullers picks up
his first strikeout right so one out
still two men on and here's adolescarcia
swing and a miss got him waving at the
slider two walks two strikeouts
in this hitting for lance i'll deal with
joey gallo
swaying and a miss ball bounces away and
this inning will continue as maldonado
has that breaking ball shoot to his left
ogallo reaches on a strikeout
and now it's chris davis to the plate
got a shot to strike out four in the
inning
and he does bow tip caught by maldonado
lance mccullers jr gets through a tight
row back in the first
chas mccormick leading it off
chaz mccormick hits one deep to right
field all the way back is gallow
chas mccormick hits a home run to make
it a three-nothing astros lead number
three on the year for chaz
mccormick has been very productive with
his seventh hit of the year
now three of them home runs has driven
in 13 runs well here's bradley
and the pitch is stroked on two hops
right to solace in short right
flings it over to first the sides
retired one run on the lead off home run
by mccormick
so two outs and two on for solac who
walked in the first
oh hit in the air to right center field
mccormick and tucker converge
who wants it mccormick finally gets
tucker to give way for the final out of
the inning
we'll get the three four and five
hitters alex bregman goes after the
first pitch
out to left field and calhoun with the
reach on the run
reels that one in for the first out of
the inning it looks like the work that
willie's done has gone a long way to
making him a much better outfielder than
he was when he first got here
all right here's gerry ellen out guriel
pops this one up could be a quick one
two
three inning low wants it and
takes care of it and so lyles with a
nice job they're nine
pitches so now a couple of base runners
for chris davis
that ball hit high in the air beyond
first base yuli guriel
will put it away for the second out of
the inning and here's isaiah kleiner
this one down the third baseline base
hit low will score easily from second
gallow being weighed frantically by tony
beasley
he'll score it's a two-run double for
isaiah kinder falafel
and they finally get through against
mccullough's
culvers in the batter now swinging a
miss mccullars junior puts
three past charlie culberson to strike
him out to end the third
here's maldonado boy it'd be great to to
get a run back
2-1 is a shot up the middle so lacks got
it the second baseman that's going to
score a run
the astros score and it's 4-2 now and
now
here's altuve two strike pitch and
that's in the air
should be the final out of the inning
calhoun coming in
garcia calls him off and adoles makes
the catch the inning is down
they low the batter he's one for two the
1-0 pitch is driven to center
mccormick over to his left will put it
away
for out number three so nice job by
mccullers there we'll go to the fifth
inning the ashrams lead 42.
brantley's at second and bregman's at
first with nobody out
and your don alvarez now coming up and a
swing
and a miss he strikes out for the first
out of the inning here's the pitch
there's a high drive to left center
field that's hit well garcia on the run
still racing in the gap he slows and he
makes the catch
nice backhand running grab by adolescent
in the inning
here's garcia goes after the first pitch
hammers that one deep out to left dawn
another one for elbow
we're talking earlier in the game about
a no doubter and that will qualify
that one reached the second deck in left
field that was gone the second he made
contact with it
i'll bring up charlie culberson lance
has retired him twice
swinging a miss mccullers jr gets
through the fifth inning
does allow a solo home run strands
another runner
maldonado is lined to third and grounded
the second driving in a run and that run
is now the difference in the game
ground ball third base culverson hops up
throws out maldonado in a one two
three sixth inning for jordan lyles he
needed just six pitches to get it done
two outs runner on first base and andre
scrub takes over
froze him on the fastball outside corner
andre skrull picks up a strikeout of
nate lowe
gets through the sixth inning draws the
walk that'll give alvarez a chance
and alvarez looks this high in the air
short right
field and solange made it clear
he wanted it he takes it and the inning
is done stretch time in
arlington bottom of the seventh inning
in a one-run game adolesce garcia will
be coming up
oh that pulls hit well deep out to left
he's done it again
el bombie's tied the game
his 14th home run and he makes it a 4-4
ball game
there's a spinner that that has home run
written all over it
well if the all-star game was tomorrow
he'd be starting in center field and
batting fourth for the american league
rangers one bad pitch away here from
loading them up there goes counter
falloffa
pitches high that's ball forward so they
are loaded jose trevino
with a chance to change the trajectory
of this game right here with one swing
the 01 swing and that ball hit high and
deep out of the left field
bradley racing back to his left this
ball is
off the wall and it kicks past mccormick
davis is in
tyner falefa coming home stopping at
third base is holt
it's a two-run double for jose trevigno
off the wall in front of the visitors
bullpen and the rangers lead for the
first time today
6-4 bases are loaded here for nate lowe
hunters will be going the 3-2 pitch and
a ground ball
that one's bobbled over a third by
bregman this sort of first
is bottled in first by dorial two-run
score
the throw to third and they will get the
out there
solac retired to win the inning but the
rangers pick up
two more as the inning comes to a close
a
five run past houston down to their
final out
of the afternoon 2-2 pitch in the air
center field garcia is back
and fittingly he makes the catch this
one is over
the rangers have taken the first two of
this series from houston 8-4
our final score this afternoon